President Trump is preparing his first
State of the Union address he will lay
out his agenda for the year tomorrow
night priorities include trade
infrastructure and immigration the White
House presents an immigration proposal
to Congress this week it creates a path
to citizenship for nearly 2 million
dreamers in exchange the president wants
25 billion dollars for border wall
changes to the Visa Lottery and an end
to so-called chain migration Republicans
senator Susan Collins is working on a
bipartisan immigration deal she says the
White House plan tries to accomplish too
much White House legislative director
Mark short says the plan will force
Congress to fix the whole immigration
system Congress has until February 8th
to reach an immigration deal or risk
another government shutdown Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer suggested
to the Washington Post that he is
unlikely to threaten another shutdown
over the issue CBS News contributor ed
O'Keefe was one of the post reporters
who wrote that article and spoke with
the senator ed good morning morning guys
ok let's talk about this immigration
debate it seems to be boiling down to
how many dreamers to protect how much
money to spend on the wall but how close
are they to a deal well the fact that
the president now says he wants to
basically grant legal status to 1.8
million essentially puts that issue to
rest so now it's a question of what
specifically would you be spending money
on along the border and how much or what
exactly would get built there but I
think the more emotional issue to keep
an eye on the issue that could become a
real flashpoint now is the debate over
family based legal migration what some
people call Shan migration but what
Democrats say is a derisive term the
idea here is who exactly would be able
to stay or get legal status with a
dreamer if it were their spouse their
children maybe their parents maybe
siblings that's the debate now that I
think is gonna royal this over the next
few days it came up briefly at the
Grammys last that's right Camila Cabello
saying this country was built by
dreamers for dreamers who were chasing
the American dream you're right that
it's going to cause a divide there it
can cause a divide in the Democratic
Party what do you mean because you're
going to continue to see Democrats
especially in the Senate who are seeking
re-election this year probably side with
Republicans or take a more conservative
position
this then Democrats who aren't or who
are thinking about running for president
in 2020 and you're gonna see that on so
many different issues throughout the
year immigration if they bring up bills
on abortion rights or other issues
related to the economy you'll see those
divides because they're running for
re-election in essentially Republican
states and what does that specifically
mean in terms of a conservative Democrat
does that mean they'll want more they'll
allow more for the border wall does it
mean yeah more narrow definition of
chain migration yeah I would think that
they would definitely be supportive and
they are supportive of changes along the
border and they might take the more
conservative stance on family based
migration and the number of dreamers
allowed in aren't conservatives a little
angry with the president for increasing
that number is that a real warrior or is
that right Bart news called them amnesty
Don because of this and yes there is
some concern and the president has
several opportunities this week to call
that concern both in his State of the
Union address when Republicans go to
West Virginia this week they're gonna
have a off-site retreat together to talk
about the year ahead president could
conceivably try to win them over there
and say guys let's let that go and focus
on other issues he says the State of the
Union will be his message will be a
unifying one he also said that at the
inauguration a lot of people term that
very differently right what does he need
to do does he need to reset the table
here it wouldn't hurt I think you keep
keep an eye out for three I words
infrastructure in all the conversations
about the economy this was the issue
that many wanted to see dominate last
year it did not and it may not this year
immigration of course what what exactly
does he say that signals what could
happen in the coming year and the third
investigations if he brings up what's
going on with him
that could sour the mood and and set the
tone in a bad way for the year ahead all
right well then we'll keep our eye on
that part of it like that yes why they
pay you the big that way these are just
devices to help follow up and learn what
you think well done all right thanks ed
we'll bring you the president's State of
the Union address tomorrow night at nine
right here on CBS John Gill and I will
leave coverage from New York well Jeff
Glor anchors from Washington our entire
political team will provide reporting
and analysis